it's 1130 is this on can you hear me all
right it's 1130 so let's get started
it's my pleasure i'm joe nash by the way
and with bill out of the country i am
introducing our speakers today and i'm
thrilled to be able to introduce mark
ingolstadt who's been at ohsu since 2011
we were so lucky to get him he came to
us from Minnesota and when I was looking
at your CV yesterday I saw he has a dds
an MD a masters in health informatics
and he did fellowships in oral and
maxillofacial surgery in the u.s.
Switzerland and Australia very
impressive background and even more
impressive is what he does here at ohsu
where he's an associate professor in two
departments in the school of medicine
including demise and in the school of
dentistry are you still interim chair
yep for another two weeks oh all right
he is presently interim chair of the
department of oral and maxillofacial
surgery in the school of dentistry he
heads up the residency program for that
department and also he has our
informatics fellowship under his wing
and I will let him introduce his fellows
in a little bit but they will be talking
about a very exciting project they've
been working on thanks Joan just hearing
all that it made me think I should ask
for a raise I do i do a lot it's before
I go any further and talk about an
applied informatics approach to a
surgical resident log I want to
introduce our other two presenters today
who working with Mike and Jeff is I
think the best part of my job and it's
really what makes me look forward to
coming to ohsu and brings everything
together allows me to bring together my
clinical world and the informatics world
Mike Grove is a pH as a PhD in
informatics from the University of
Minnesota and Michael and I actually met
when I was a grad student
getting my masters we started our
program at the same time Mike went on to
get a PhD and and then came here to ohsu
as a National Institute for dental and
craniofacial research informatics fellow
which is really analogous to being an
NLM fellow it's really the same thing
but it's sort of under the auspices of
the nidcr which is a branch of the NIH
that really concentrates on oral and
craniofacial health our other presenter
is Jeff MA and Jeff got his master's
degree in bioinformatics here at ohsu
and just completed it recently last year
and is now a PhD candidate predock
fellow I always get the terminology
wrong he's a pre-doctoral fellowship
program and we really work together as a
team on this so today we're going to
talk about the whole context behind this
why did this project get started how did
it make sense what are we doing what are
the some of the challenges we came
across and are going to come across and
where are we going with this thing Jeff
is going to talk about the architecture
of this application that we've built
mike is going to talk to you about the
ontological model that powers the
reasoning and the influencing behind it
and then we're going to give you a demo
of this working product hopefully we can
leave enough time for the demo because
that might be the fun part so how did
this all come apart or all come together
well as John mentioned I'm a program
director so I run a residency training
program that's probably my biggest
surgical role and I deal with residents
and I'm an educator and a big component
of residency training for hundreds of
years has been the surgical log that's
how residents have always documented
what they've done who they've treated
what disease processes have they've
managed what surgeries have they done
what credentials do they have what
privileges can they get so the log is a
constant thing in surgery
but as I got informatics training I
realized the disconnect between the way
logs have been kept the last several
decades which is in billing
terminologies like I CD and cpt which
are great if you're going to ask an
insurance company for payment they work
wonderfully for that but they are really
bad what they are really inefficient
representations of what happens in the
educational realm what happens in the
clinical care realm when one of my
residents goes to log a case and let's
say he did a facial artery muscle mucosa
flap a fam flap and he says gosh i know
i did a fam flap with dr ingolstadt i'm
going to go and log that now in my log
and in the log he searches the log looks
for fam flap looks for fam clap can't
find it doesn't exist so then that
resident who has you know limited amount
of knowledge certainly isn't an expert
in billing is forced to look at the
whole list decide by deductive reasoning
which thing on the list most represents
the thing that he did and maybe if he's
he or she is really bright they will
finally settle on the appropriate code
which is rotated flap header neck ten
centimeters or less which of course
doesn't it all represent what he did
that's sort of a generalized term but
that process cognitively is extremely
fatiguing you know when you know what
something is called can't find it but
are forced to search a list for another
thing that might represent it it leads
to us saving data that really doesn't
represent the real world and its really
really annoying for the resident to have
to do that so what we're missing in logs
is really structured granular clinical
domain information I know what things
are called I say things like I say I did
a fam flap I don't go around saying I
really did a great head neck flap
rotated ten centimeters or less today
you know I've never said that ever and
none of my residents will ever say that
so let's build tools that actually use
the words and phrases that we use and a
tool that really captures
the special characteristics of
educational demands so what are some of
these special characteristics in this
little domain of oral and maxillofacial
surgery which crosses the bridge between
dentistry and medicine well one of the
special educational demands is that our
logs have to generate reports that
satisfy accreditation requirements
that's one of the big reasons for
keeping a log so that I can accredit my
training program people can site visit
me and I can show them information that
says see look what we did look what we
treated we should be accredited right
now these accreditation reports can be
put on anything at PDF Excel spreadsheet
word document a paper napkin whatever
you want and so a goal would be to
structure the information so that it can
be used very efficiently for
accreditation to meet accreditation
requirements one really special cool
thing about our domain that allows us to
do this project that might be much more
difficult to do and say orthopedic
surgery or general surgery is that
because we're accredited by coda and
coda doesn't make demands on our log we
can experiment with new log formulas if
I was accredited by the American Council
on graduate medical education acgme
which accredits most surgical training
programs I would have very limited
ability to experiment with a log because
their log rules are much more
restrictive so because I'm in this
little domain we can experiment and
that's why OMS is such a special place
to do this I am the chair of a committee
that is involved in setting up
establishing a national resident
surgical log and that committee is a
part of our American Association of oral
and maxillofacial surgery which is the
national professional committee in my
field so we we are a sort of well
positioned to get this product that
we're making rolled out to hopefully all
training programs in the United States
another stakeholder in this are the
residents they need to know what they
did they want to be able to use in form
a
to go to their program director and say
you know I don't have a lot of
experience in this area over here how
can you help me right now they really
can't do that and of course the
educators need information and when I
meet with a resident I got 20 minutes to
sit I have a half an hour an hour to sit
down with them devise an individual
achievement plan devised a learning plan
and if my information is really hard to
decipher and interpret then building
those plans are really difficult so it
took a long time to develop an actual
you know idea of what we're doing and
how do we bring all these pieces
together it's a grand plan but this is
the our idea in encapsulation we hope to
develop a standardized oral and
maxillofacial surgery training log
that's intuitive and semantically rich
that can improve education reporting in
clinical research so we have to take
events like this where there's a
diseased patient and there's a surgery
that's happening and somehow we have to
transmit that very very unstructured
information into a formula that's
actually structured so a lot of times in
registries and databases and things like
that people take unstructured
information like clinical notes and they
make it structured like a database by
hiring a nurse or a study coordinator or
somebody like that well nurses and study
coordinators are very very expensive
people and they can only work at a
certain rate so one big challenge in
building any database is who is going to
enter the information who's going to
read that chart or enter or say what I
did to that patient and put it in this
special place over here that's a huge
problem well we have people who are
going to do that and they're called
residence right and they're really
really special and I recognize that log
data has so much potential and why it's
so valuable it took me a little while
but I realized that bloom in medicine in
healthcare we are always struggling to
find struck
shirred piles of data that we can
actually turn our informatics tools on
and actually find out things you know
learn things about health care and
science and medicine where's that data
going to come from you know the the
dream of it coming just right out of the
EHR certainly hasn't happened and so we
are we are really starving for
structured piles of data that we can we
can we can use so I realized that these
residents are really special first of
all their domain experts they know what
everything is called they don't have to
be trained they don't have to be sent to
a course they know the name of
everything and they know what things are
called they also have a they also
overcome one of the obstacles which is
incentive they have an incentive to
enter the data there they're competitive
by nature they don't like to be the one
who did the least and they have to get
credentials and they have to get
privileges and we live in a world of
ever-increasing verification gone are
the days when you can just show a
certificate and say ah see I did a
residency and boy I'm ready to go to get
privileges and credentials you have to
show people that you are trained to do
things that you are trained to manage
specific disease processes and so they
have a high incentive to log their cases
if we make it easy for them and if you
think about any database what you really
want is national information and that's
the thing that's super hard to come by
it's possible for you to get information
out of ohsu but if you want to build the
database that collects clinical data
educational data which is clinical data
if you want to build this and organize
it and have it come from multiple
sources and multiple institutions that
is an extremely complex thing to
coordinate and build with IRB
limitations and a whole bunch of things
so resident data is really interesting
because it is both educational which is
what allows us to pull it all together
nationally but if we collect it in the
right way we can use it secondarily for
clinical
research if you were just collecting
clinical data you would have to satisfy
a huge amount of IRB limitations before
you could collect national clinical
information but we're collecting
primarily educational information and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
later so let's say we had a tool that
could peer into a big national database
of findings and procedures what would we
want to do with it I might as a program
director ask a question like I want to
know how many malignant salivary gland
pathologic processes a certain resident
has managed in order for me to ask a
simple question like that the system has
to know what's a salivary gland
pathologic process and what's a
malignant process and how many of it has
a certain people as a certain person
done and and from an informatics
standpoint that is not easy I might want
to know is my training program providing
adequate experience and flute and free
flap reconstruction compared to national
averages in order to know that I have to
know what national averages are the
machine has to know what a free flap is
and that requires influencing and
reasoning the residents another
stakeholder is may want to ask their
program director or may want to know if
they need more experience in a certain
domain of surgery right now by any log
system that exists anywhere there really
isn't any way for a learner to challenge
their teacher and say I am deficient in
a certain area without spending a large
amount of time searching their log and
maybe collecting information from other
places it's not easy to do and I think a
good log should tell people what you've
done and what others have done and where
you're still deficient so we can educate
people a researcher might want to query
this information and ask well when I win
used to try when used to treat associate
when used to treat a finding associated
with inflammation of any facial bone
structure our debridement or total
excision procedures followed by fewer
free flap reconstruction procedures now
that's a big question basically that's a
a question that's formed in a very
logical way that asks which procedure
works better because it's followed by
fewer procedures and right now there are
no logs that can do that or a researcher
might want to ask I'm thinking of
building a study where can I find
patients that have had an excision of
one branch of a cranial nerve that also
had grafting that were later followed by
removal of the graft it seems like a
simple question but for you to pore over
records and logs right now that would
take months just to find out if those
patients even existed so our log takes
clinical findings takes procedures which
are educational events the motivated
surgical trainee logs the finding logs
the procedure into an OMS database then
we have stakeholders like accreditation
agencies program directors surgeons
students surgical residents or
researchers that are going to query the
database through an ontology which can
use the information in a database reason
with it inference it and give
information back to those stakeholders
our plan is to start an ohsu obviously
and get this thing working then over the
next few years build a relationship with
five to ten other sites that have shown
a lot of interest in being part of this
project and then after working out the
kinks that come with working in multiple
sites then roll it out to one hopefully
at least eighty percent of the hundred
existing training programs right now
there we already have a national log so
the idea of getting this rolled out to
every trading program really isn't too
pie-in-the-sky because most logs that
already exists exists in every training
program in that domain or field and with
that introduction I'm going to pass this
over to Mike to talk to you about the
ontology behind this and I'll just
briefly touch on this and we'll get into
more specific examples
from our actual project but this just a
couple of quick slides for those who are
not familiar with the idea of an
ontology and what it can do as Mark said
we're trying to model a complex domain
like surgery and not rely on these on
billing codes and so forth which words
which aren't built to understand the
semantics of what's occurring in a
surgical setting from an educational
standpoint and a clinical standpoint so
an ontology just at the highest level as
a set of classes or concepts that are
related to one another using properties
so it allows you for allows you to
perform inferencing and classification
over large aggregated data sets so a
really simplified example here is we can
imagine that we're using an axiom at our
ontology in other words we're making an
assertion a statement about our domain
and we're saying in plain language which
an ontology is able to speak speak about
a domain in a plain language while
simultaneously being machine processable
so but in plain language we would say in
our ontology that any sense organ that
functions in the detection of smell is
no factory sense organs we have a class
sense organ in Iran Tala G we have a
class olfactory sense organ and we have
a property relationship of capable of
detection of smell so we see that the
confluence of the two categories result
in a new class olfactory sense organ so
that's modeled in an ontology at a
generic example so what that can do is
if we look at if we add an instance of a
nose which is a sense organ into our
ontology and we also annotate it with a
the property type capable of detection
of smell you're able to through
classification infer that the nose is an
olfactory sense oregon based on the
initial model so we're not in other
words we're not saying this in the
ontology model but by annotating our
data with the ontology model we're able
to infer this and so it's a really
simplified example but you can imagine
over a large complex data set this
starts to owner it's a lot of really
detailed knowledge that you just can't
figure out through human review of that
data or it just you know just it's too
complex and too large so that's just
that's the basic sort of conceptual
informatics underpinning of this log
which gives it the power that makes
pretty cool and I believe Jeff I'll hand
over to Jeff to talk about sort of the
architecture of the whole application
okay so we called this a blended
architecture and the reason for that is
most medical or business transactional
systems record transactions and logs the
events are transactions are based more
or less on a traditional rdb relational
database oh the the transactions are are
the information is read from the
database the transactions are written
back to the database in order to aid our
residents and selecting more
semantically rich or more granular
records or selections for both their
findings and their procedures we've
developed a taking the approach of using
what is called a a triple storm will
talk about this in a little while that
is based on a solar lusine triple store
so this takes the place of a database
for powering the term selection once the
terms are selected and the events are
written they are written to the database
and all of this information that power
is this triple store is driven out of is
extracted from and driven from the
ontology that Mike spoke of and then it
uses a typical a lamp based architecture
or stack and that we're using Linux this
is hosted by acc Linux is the operating
system Apache reasonable to patching the
Apache Tomcat in particular server it's
a Java server page server so that serves
up most of the GUI mysql is a database
we're not using the p normal that stands
for python or PHP or one of these others
and the place we're using pure java and
javaserver pages and it served out and
available just through a standard web
browser so what is the advantage why go
to all this trouble so pop-up list
pop-up list for everybody and in
particular for residents when they're
trying to find some
granular somewhat verbose listing is
painful to you they're hardened navigate
they can be slow and sometimes painfully
slow both in their presentations there's
a lot of choices and in their ability to
find what you want to select it so we as
I spoke up we're using this triple store
driven list it allows querying by
multiple criteria I want to find a
diagnosis it needs to contain the word
mandibular you have a variety of things
and the key thing is that it's very fast
it's almost I mean will shun the demo
one second or less response to the
queries or to the changes and again as I
mentioned it's ontology-based and the
ontology we can model these complex
relations we can then extract those
through a set of tools and represent
them in this triple store now the rdb is
kind of a traditional relational
database schema it has a lot of look up
stuff if you will the program the
educational program the people involved
in this their positions sites and
settings so marks residents work at
varieties not just at ohsu legacy
Providence in those sites there are
multiple settings there could be the
hatfield clinic inpatient outpatient
clinics varieties of things but the key
the central thing here the big table you
see here is the event and there's some
subtleties involved in this and that
multiple residents can be involved in
one of these surgical events and they
can play different roles there could be
the primary surgeon a secondary surgeon
a teaching surgeon occasionally or an
observer and we develop this such that
in the current system in most systems a
single resident say the primary enters
in the the record and then annotate sit
with who was the secondary or the
additional residents and hours each
resident will be entering in a separate
event
they will select their own procedures
and diagnosis and you could say well
this is somewhat redundant but it
actually as you think through this
provides some wealth here and that let's
say we have three residents primary
surgeon is secondary and observer each
of those is going to use the system and
independently log the event from their
perception there's no guarantee they're
going to pick the same bindings there's
no guarantee they'll pick the same
procedure it may provide may provide a
wealth of research opportunity to
understand do the perception of the
surgical event change as residents
proceed through the first year or second
year perceive it the same as a fifth or
sixth year resident so it's particularly
structured to do that each resident will
be responsible entering their
participation in the other thing that
kind of differs from like an epic or
some of the traditional EHRs is that our
procedures and our find our diagnosis
this is a mini to mini table that is a
and like epic for example I believe if
you associate a finding right diagnosis
with an an order prescription you can
only associate it with one there's a
one-to-one relationship enforce and this
you can associate a procedure with
multiple findings of finding with
multiple procedures and again this
provides perhaps a richness of potential
differences depending on how it's long
enough on that so the triple store this
kind of a key to this the triple store
is called that because it's predicated
on this concept of a resource
description framework the RDF this kind
of underpins a lot of the semantic work
the standard is approved by the World
Wide Web Consortium and it's a triple
that is composed of three pieces a
subject so for instance repair of the
unilateral cleft lip a predicate it has
a site and an object that this operate
the predator operates as
upper lip structure so everything that's
in the ontology can be distilled down
and represented in this set of triples
and our triple store is essentially the
the storage really at the file system
level of all of the triples that are
inferred or stated in the underlying
ontology now the advantage of this is
much like the cache a database under
pending epic is that it's fast it
doesn't have the speed or penalty
implications of doing multiple multiple
joins that an RD beef may have and we'll
see this in our demo now to make this
happen we essentially use a set of again
Apache libraries it's called the solar
lusine this is a way of taking these
triples and indexing them for very fast
reading and retrieval at the file system
level and then the Jenna framework
begins a set of Java classes that are
used to actually access this triple
store and pass the data onto the GUI we
didn't have a set of tools that we have
to use we have to extract a subset from
the snow sno-med CT underpins all this
we have takes no bits CT as a source we
then add on to it through marks clinical
knowledge and extend it so we have a set
of tools called the owl tools there a
wrapper around a whole set of java stuff
it essentially let's say non java
programmer use these tools and do things
with them we have another one that's
actually a similar one called ort it
really extract the data out of the
ontology and provide it ready to use for
the triple store and then we have our
processor we used a lot of custom java
to analyze stuff and get things
essentially going to begin with I think
I'll turn it over to Mike now so this so
this Jeff mentioned we have a snow med
CT base that we started with to
developer ontology just because sno-med
is is a pretty
large well-established clinic clinical
terminology with 340,000 something odd
concepts or something already
represented in a in a sort of ontology
ontological model so what Mark did with
his domain expertise is start to build
out and extend on that model of sno-med
so to build from the tilt to build the
granularity that we're talking about
that this ontology support so to do that
mark used his favorite little snowflake
browser here which is a nice way to look
at sno-med and he started looking at
concepts and said hey reconstruction of
mandible that's in sno-med that's a
one-to-one match for that we want for
our ontology that's what a clinician
talks about at that level it's important
to a researcher clinician secondly he
would find a concept like yeah
reconstruction mandible however
reconstruction of mandible by
distraction is a concept of granularity
that we want to have in our database so
this was a partial match which he then
enhanced and then we model in the
ontology and then third hey I'm I want
something really granular like
reconstruction of bony mandible alveolar
process with bone graft including BMP
you know whatever that word salad is
there so that in that case we just
modeled a brand new concept so that's an
entirely new granular so you can see the
level of granularity we're talking about
in our concept so that would be like one
of the nodes in a subject object
predicates triple and so I can say we
merged it all into an existing sno-med
extracts we leverage the size and the
expressiveness of an existing sno-med
subset a really important piece in the
last mark too if you want to comment on
this as well of the ontologies that we
also developed mark developed you can do
the math here find clinical finding and
procedure educational categories so
these are brand new categories that we
developed and incorporate it into the
ontology that are meant to allow us to
capture the educational experiences that
of the particular composed procedure and
diagnosis right and raised in a lot
these would be categories like malignant
process there's really no existing way
even in sno-med things aren't separated
by whether or not it's malignant that
would be a sort of a finding category
but
for an educator I want to know if my
students have managed malignant disease
processes because that's a completely
separate educational pyramid of
knowledge on the procedure side I might
want to ask how are you doing in
orthognathic surgery well how do you
define orthognathic surgery sno-med
doesn't define what orthognathic surgery
is it's kind of a special niche thing I
have to define that but I have
accreditation requirements that need to
show how much orthognathic surgery ja
straightening surgery that my residents
have done and so I've built these
educational categories to serve the
accrediting bodies and to serve the
educators the triple store is really to
serve serve the researchers and to power
our searches but we had to build these
educational categories to serve the
educational side of things and you'll
notice that you see finding in all of
our systems procedure in all of our
systems but there are no outcomes
there's no way to know how people did if
I was to collect outcomes then I'm
collecting purely clinical data that is
an educational per se so we can't
collect outcomes but we can infer a lot
of information about outcomes based on
patients who had one procedure for a
finding and then maybe had a second
procedure that would be a procedure you
would only do if the first procedure
didn't work out very well so we can
infer a great deal about how procedures
did scientifically by the actions that
followed them but there are no outcomes
per se sure and just to speak briefly to
what he said about the is modeled in the
ontology itself that drives all of this
each concept in Iran tala G is given at
least one educational class type
relation based on our clinical expert
over here quickly don't worry about the
details of this but this is basically
the axiom so if you remember my first
slide about here's a generic axiom of an
ontology this is how we express our
axioms our procedure our findings and
our procedures in our database they're
connected with our concept classes which
are the cup
boxes and the property types which we
have in between them and their
associated with in the log itself
through in the graphical user interface
their associated through the event table
that Jeff pointed out on the rdb so in
layman's terms you can just think of
this as this is how we express our
finding and this is how we express our
procedure and just as an example of what
this actually looks like using an
example of an instance we have our
finding express up here unilateral cleft
lip is it is an oral maxillofacial
surgery ontology concept it has the
anatomical site using a structure class
set from sno-med of anatomy sites upper
lip structure and it has the education
category craniofacial so similarly down
here is the procedure that it's been
associated with that in an event entry
by a single role member in a surgical
procedure so you might have three
different sets of these axioms for three
people that were in the same room for
the three for one particular event that
makes sense and then just to throw back
quickly to jeff's triple you can see
subject predicate and object an example
of any ontology how that looks so that
relationship there is a triple this
relationship is a triple and then
similarly down here we have another set
of triples so that's all you can start
to imagine all the null all the granular
sets of data that are generated from
modeling using an ontology this is a
screenshot of our sort of beta version
of the graphical user interface of a
concept as it sits in there so you can
see we've got this was our search box so
somebody typed in you know they wanted
they were looking for something men
dibbler related well using the triple
store model it quickly gave them the
option of selecting this particular term
so you can see that it's got the
anatomical site the educational
categories you can move up and down the
hierarchy that we have modeled in the
ontology so if you're interested in a
more granular concept or a more general
concept you're not sure you're in the
right place we also have clinical domain
definitions that we're developing for
each one of these concepts that marks
clinicians will help fill out because we
have
a large set of terms to define we have a
uniform resource identifier which is a
generic ID number for this concept to
mitigate any changes in the concept over
time so if we decide based on domain
feedback that this name needs to change
we still map it back to this ID number
so we don't lose any information that we
have linked to that particular concept
and importantly we have our icd-9 icd-10
mappings and any related sno-med concept
idea mappings as well I just want to say
one thing too if you look under
congenital mandibular hypoplasia you'll
see other terms our system recognizes
synonyms which is extremely important
because what I call something other
people will call it different I might
say that I treated auricula temporal
syndrome others might call that
gustatory sweating or fri syndrome or
von fries syndrome but the entity is
what it is no matter what label you put
on it it is this uniform resource
indicator and so our system recognizes
synonyms which is really important
because it doesn't require then
everybody around the country to call
things to all call this the same thing
clinicians don't like that they learned
a certain way to call this and name this
and they won't change so I give them the
ability to use the synonym that they
like and map it back to the actual label
that we prefer which really helps
utilization let me point out that you
just said synonym like eight times
without doing cinnamon yeah which is
very good pretty very good but if you
any of you think about it another
another language is just a synonym so
why not add German or Hindi or Farsi or
doesn't matter because this is what it
is no matter what label you put on it so
this you know the idea is to extend it
to other languages as well and then
quickly so we keep moving here just the
ontology itself it's curated in a
protege ontology editor environment you
can render it in these different
interoperable languages Jeff mentioned
owl a few times it's the web ontology
language in case you're not familiar
with that which is a standard ontology
modeling language we keep the sub
versions
of it in a github repository where we
also have a term tracker which is where
we can collect feedback from the domain
to figure out are these are we using the
right level of granularity and the terms
you know what's the domain say about our
ontology so we're not just wasting this
upon his domain and currently we have
you can see we pulled 7,200 or so
sno-med classes in this initial poll
based on the January 31st 2014 sno-med
version and we currently have 1900
procedure concepts unique to the OMS
ontology and about 1800 finding terms as
well so 10,000 or so classes at this
point it's a pretty significant corpus
yes yes yes I mean a lot of the classes
from sno-med are not there just no no it
was a very sno-med SAT up here and and
Mark is built out you saw the one slide
where I had the word salad you know that
stuff is incredibly detailed and
that'sthat's all marks his relationship
with these spreadsheets he's been
working on is pathological so but you
know it works for us so and then I think
we'll just kind of all talk about the
next steps from our particular
viewpoints here mark you honey so for
the next 30 day hopefully in the next 30
days we're going to deploy this operate
it works will show you the demo we've
got a couple of little things to fix and
get the get it out to the residents in
the next 30 days they already have a log
it it's it's an e-value which is an
application used to help manage training
programs again I want to get that data
that's an e-value into this new log so
already our new log has a whole bunch of
data in it and the residents don't lose
the continuity which would be very
annoying for them to have to have their
experience in multiple different logging
systems we're going to get a lot of
feedback from our ohsu residents and
make improvements we're going to
generate for the first time ever an
accreditation report really detailed one
from our log that'll be one of our goals
and hopefully ideally build reports and
data visualizations which
help a program director sit down with a
resident during their six-month review
and look at data visualizations like
this like this heat map of experience in
certain anatomical areas in the area of
bony surgery there's no reason at all
because this is semantically rich log
there's no reason that at all that we
can't create averages for say surgical
experience that involves operating on
the eye socket our system knows what the
eye socket is every surgery and we can
create averages of experience and tell a
resident well you're below average in I
socket surgery you are really good in
mandible and zygoma you're a little
deficient and mid-face and you haven't
done a lot of nasal surgery have been
involved in surgical procedures that
involve the site of nasal skeleton
that's really really useful if you're a
student or if you're an educator to know
that you have these deficiencies how can
you correct a deficiency you don't know
exists and you have the power now to go
to your program director who maybe
hasn't done what they need to do and say
you know I'm deficient in this area and
I would like you to help me get
education in this area it's our question
into that would these heat maps be
weighted by whether the training is a
the primary surgeon a secondary or
observing it could be and that would be
a good point to know there's there's
almost a limitless depth of how detailed
you can get and the only question would
be how much data do you want and how
much makes a difference in your in your
educational planning but there is a
difference let's say and I wouldn't
expect a first-year to have a lot of
experience in eye socket surgery so
that's totally legit but they're
compared to other first years so they're
experience levels always compared to
people like them but this is in the
future
so we want to know what questions you
have and then we're going to do a demo
of the log should I log in while you
guys are chatting Oh before we forget I
think we should do the acknowledgments
now I want to thank the School of
Dentistry which has spent helped us fund
this project with my startup research
money and dr. Phil maruka the Dean of
our school of dentistry who has helped
to extend that support the nidcr are
Mike and Jeff's sponsors for their
fellowship Melissa handle is our on toll
is our ontology development group
scientific leader and she's been really
helpful the ACC specifically colma can
dish at the ACC has really helped us set
up the instance and get all the the
application framework stuff going and
Ted bashor is an independent software
engineer out of Wonder Lake software
who's written a lot of the extremely
specialized highly specialized code that
involves using RDF and these very
specialized tools so I'm going to log on
while you guys take a question what I'll
do here is that as part of this we you
have to login to enter an event but
we've also made available without
logging in the query tool this is just
to currently present it to our residents
and just to allow them to play with the
interface so it drives against the
triple store just like if you were
selecting the thing is you couldn't you
cannot save anything into the database
and so I'll pass this around it skills
relatively well to a pad and without any
training or anything we'll just let you
play with it by touching it and seeing
what you get and what marks logging in
and doing it more formal president you
can't break anything so unless you're
spill your coke on the Hat yes
oh sorry so you were saying the two
types of resident so first year and say
a six year and theoretically they can
they can call the case something
different absolutely the diagnosis can
be different in the procedure can be
different how would you then deal with
that when it comes time to look at when
someone wants to use this data now and
then you know someone calls something a
mandible fracture you know someone calls
something that sub condylar fracture
which part of the mandible ah how would
you deal with that later on because
essentially you need to have two events
there and so or if you're looking at I
guess some so you'd have two events each
one associated with a specific resident
mm-hmm okay so we don't really know yet
how we're going to handle this so and
that your example in that theoretical
heat map those would both map up into
the same structure in that example
however this is one of the very
interesting parts for us is how do what
differences will show between a first
year and a fifth year or six year so how
are we going to handle it we don't know
yet I think that through its usage as
you say during a six-month or yearly
review residents is found to be lacking
in certain areas it could be because
they haven't had the exposure the
experiences it could be because they're
not logging it appropriately and
hopefully this we part of an iterative
cycle of both education for the resident
themselves for them to learn I guess
that consensus on what they really did
see and you would hope that it would
become more consistent as the years and
a program go by but essentially time
will tell and I think I understand
Mike's question in a slightly different
way so two people might call things a
different thing but no matter what
there's no way to
so if a human says they saw something
then that's what they saw that's what
they did if you have a conflict and you
want to know what actually happened you
would then have to refer to the medical
record if you had some sort of conflict
that you had action now for you might be
envisioning an accreditation body that
wants to know what you've done it's
unlikely the accreditation body is going
to care if you did an orbital floor
fracture or a medial orbital wall
fracture the two things are so similar
that from an accreditation standpoint
they are not necessarily important and
right and right now one resident can log
whatever they want another resident
kamagra tever they want you'll never you
can write what you want the medical
record i can write what i want your
version of what reality is can only be
reconciled by you for the next question
I know interrupted um but I mean I think
your example highlights really one of
the advantages of an ontology where if
one student says they did surgery on the
mandible and another selection more
granular term like part of the mandible
the knowledge encoded in the ontology
there's a relationship between the
mandible and all the parts of the
mandible so the knowledge encoded in the
ontology will infer that surgery on the
part of the mandible is the type of
surgery on the mandible and if you do a
query for all surgeries on the mandible
the any more granular terms that are
annotated will be returned for that as
well because in the knowledge encoded
and they'll tell you so that's a great
example of where the ontology can help
roll up your data and an inference to
give you that type of result and there
may be other types of of disagreements
that aren't handled in that way but in
the case of different levels of
granularity that people annotate things
which is going to be common the ontology
is really valuable for resolving those
types of things so for each event we
have a resident who in this case as me
I'm not the resident the event the day
took place the date the event took place
this will be Auto populated so
the RET this allows me to track how much
experience a surgeon has the resident
will not have to enter it every time
it'll just auto populate where it
happened the setting it happened in what
their role was in this educational event
were they the primary surgeon or the
assistant surgeon who will have a
definition of that but I can adjudicate
it if somebody says their primary
surgeon then they are a primary surgeon
primary assisting observer and teaching
and these all have specific definitions
which will come up the attending is dr.
Bell we do collect a medical record
number which is salted hashed encrypted
in our database so that we can return
what did you call it a two-way it's a
two-way encryption because unlike the
password we're using very strong
encryption on the actual password to get
in that's called one way it's much like
if you forget to password your bank
account you can't they can't tell you
what it is all they can do is set a new
one for you same thing here once you set
a password and it gets encrypted nobody
has the power to read what it is other
than they try real hard cracking or
using extremely sophisticated encryption
for the password the mrn is slightly
different in that again for the
potential accrediting questions they're
really the record of truth in this is
mark alluded is in our case is epic it's
the EHR so you have to have a link back
to be able to get if necessary for
accreditation research back into the EHR
as really the truth and so we do use the
mrn it's two-way that is it's it's
encrypted going in but you have to be
able to read it there would be incentive
for a resident to overstate their
experience level and in the crediting
body needs to audit that and say well
actually no you know so there has to be
has to be a trail back to the EHR or
else the record can't be audited it's
just it could theoretically be made up
and then instead of birth date we
collect birth year which helps us know
if it's pediatric surgery or adult
surgery but it's way way simpler which
isn't
important the accreditation thing you
have to know how much pediatric surgery
residents doing but I don't need to know
what day their birth would they were
they were born on so it makes it a
little bit easier just to select a birth
year rather than a birthday is there a
question you mentioned before that when
you plan to ship us out to other
locations you expect people to use
different terms for the same thing or
synonyms this actually I don't know to
me this presents an interesting
opportunity for a longitudinal study
because if you present people with a
training tool that has a fix ontology
the language or use of language may
change over time and you could track
whether people start to use language in
a standardized way because of your tool
yeah that's a great that doesn't like we
never even thought of but you're right
it's a lot of fun to think of the
different things you can do with the
data so wrapped up here we have our
event details which are hidden but
they're still there and I've never done
this in a live setting before and this
isn't our latest iteration but would
anybody like to throw out a diagnosis
okay so right now you know right now
you'd have to in existing logs you'd
have to go to a list and and and hear
what I might do is just type in n asep
and every thing that has that text in it
comes up and you can see that that took
way less than a second now this is
extremely cognitively simple if you make
it simple for the trainee they will
enter very good data if you make them
search a list they will enter whatever
they can quickly find and get done with
right we have one opportunity here to
capture granular information and if you
make somebody go look at a list or go
look at an abstract billing concept
you've missed your opportunity to
actually collect what you want to
collect so there's your diagnosis of a
perforated nasal septum and so we might
repair here we just have fracture of
nasal septum
so let's say that we repaired that
fractured nasal septum and then we have
another diagnosis like let's say we did
in the middle of blastoma of the jaw and
then we did let's say excision of lesion
and I type all these excision of lesion
I don't really see what I need so i'll
type in mandible ok there it is and it
was in the mandibular symphysis so
that's about as cognitively simple as
you can make something using as few key
strokes as possible because most of this
will probably be entered on mobile
devices then in order to complete the
transaction the person has to associate
the diagnosis that you see up here is d
with the procedure and we've made that
very easy by having them just in drop
down menu menu so the perforation and
nasal septum is associated with with
that and you also see that populated
down here and the ameloblastoma is
associated with the excision of the
lesion of mandeville symphysis and
that's also populated down here the
resident can now close out the event in
addition they may not really know what
something is called or they might want
to look at options or the term finder
will actually have a lot of possible
uses but here we have a term finder
which is a tool that leverages all this
information that doesn't necessarily
have to be used to log a case it can but
we can use a filter type mechanism to
choose what you did so a resident might
say gosh I know I i know i did a trauma
surgery i know i did a trauma
oh yeah repair
injury so I know I treated something
that was injured I can't remember what
he called it it was injured it was in
the skeleton it was in the face it was
in the mandible and it had something in
there about koro something so i'll type
in CEO so here you can see all of the
diagnostic findings that would be an
injury of the skeleton of the facial
skeleton in the mandible that had that
text string in it and this allows people
who aren't domain experts to search for
things using greater categorization and
you could do the same thing for
procedures now you're left with a set of
very limited options that are extremely
cognitively simple to select from and if
you wanted to you could enter them as an
event in your in your log go into one I
want to highlight so along with the
searching until we get one up Lochan
just where everywhere it's just a bigger
procedure and go into it alone so once
you hear you kind of left the the term
search and you actually have entered the
tree or if you will the tree of the
ontology and now what it shows how is
that well we're at the bar I put in
mandibular hyperplasia how about this
one ah there we are now what when it has
an arrow or underneath it so yeah my dip
your hyperplasia works really well so
resident comes up enters ends up here
however they got your main Dubrow
hyperplasia and they look at this and
this display tells them if you look at
this there are more granular terms
underneath this and you see here
bilateral hypoplasia mandibular and so
there's four other that are narrower and
also if you wanted to go up you can go
up to the disorder of the mandible and
you can start your way back down so this
allows a
resident to navigate through this very
complex on to ontology if you will
through narrower and broader categories
until they can hopefully find what they
want and there's a lot of subtleties in
here that will come and train so for
instance the the italics indicates that
this itself disorder of jaw go ahead and
click on that that's not mine its order
ja that is not selectable the domain
expert is deemed that this is too
general to be used for a procedure you
notice up there that the Select let me
see the laser right there that the
yeah anyway the Select is great it
couldn't be selected but go back to
where we were yeah okay let's so okay
yeah well enough of that there's a lot
of subtleties in this interface to help
guide the residents in the selection or
make it easier for them to find more
granular as opposed to more general
terms a potential usefulness in terms of
quality like surgeons being able to say
the number of redo or second operations
have to do or variation from a public
health perspective of procedures that
are only done in one region of the
country that no one's doing anymore
absolutely it will have location data
and since we we can track that which
procedures are done on a single
individual it would be possible to infer
that when you collect information in a
way that a computer can reason or
perform logic on it then lots of really
interesting things become possible
especially when it's national data and
you get into all kinds of curious
questions that make people wonder and
think and squirm a little bit more don't
you think that outcomes are educational
they are but but I can't the recording
outcomes adds another layer of
complexity that makes the project not
succeed and it's hard for me from it to
get this through I have to make it
relevant to accreditation agencies and
they just about lost their lunch when I
said I was going to keep a medical
record number and so an outcome would be
very difficult to project it would
impound it it would compound the
difficulty and it would impound the
project so I do think they're
educational but we can't use them
because they they present us with too
much difficulty and an outcome isn't
known well now come when at six months
and who's going to log it yeah yeah if
defined all these other educational
concepts you could define educational
concepts or outcomes to
one last question mark you talked about
it the south coast is very interesting
you talked about inferring outcomes how
do you account for loss of fat loss to
follow-up in this though you can't count
for loss of follow-up you can't count
for the fact that the resident enters
the wrong data but if you have a big
enough pile of data then those sorts of
things come out in the wash they I'm not
sure of the exact Schewel statistical
yeah statistical term that that didn't
come out but since you have to assume
then that all procedures have a dropout
rate then the dropout rate becomes
equally applied to every type of surgery
you do then it no longer can that's not
really an important component in looking
at outcomes when you're looking at
millions of data points have you done in
a usability testing with the residents
yet or is that what's happening in 30
days that's what's happening in 30 days
yeah they'll find all kinds of issues
and bugs and unfortunately they are
really they tell me immediately I think
they do at least and
also developed training
well it's been a lot of work so it's
been a lot of fun talking to you about
this labor and sharing it with you and
hopefully some of you have some comments
or recommendations for us based on this
thanks a lot for coming and listening to
our our product project